[Applause]
president jair bolsonaro is adamant
there will be no national lockdown even
as brazil confirmed
its first case of the highly contagious
south african coronavirus variants
brazil has lost control of a pandemic
and that's dangerous
with infections spreading rapidly the
virus will continue mutating
and new variants may be immune to the
vaccines we already have
doctors and scientists have called for a
three-week nationwide lockdown
as the country reached another grim
milestone
four thousand brazilians died on tuesday
alone
mayors and governors have taken measures
to keep people at home
and stop the deadly outbreak which is
killing one person
every 20 seconds restrictions have also
been imposed in brazilian slums
like rio de janeiro's hossinia where
social distancing
is almost impossible and rules are not
often respected
the situation has become so serious that
the drug gangs that rule
this slum and other slums in rio de
janeiro have decreed
a lockdown and they have forbidden all
clandestine
parties from happening a bolsonaro
strongly opposes
any restrictive measures
we won't accept measures that force us
to stay home the kovit-19 virus has come
to stay
as others have in the past what are we
to do in the meantime
watch poverty rise and stop people from
working and eating
poverty rates have tripled in six months
since the government first reduced
then suspended the financial emergency
aid
it had been giving 68 million brazilians
monthly handouts stopped in january and
have just resumed on tuesday
as the country faces the worst phase of
the pandemic
with the health care system on the brink
of collapse
manika yanakiv al-jazeera rio de janeiro